[Music]
this episode is brought to you by
morning brew
hi welcome to another episode of cold
fusion so just a couple of things before
we get started
thanks for all of your comments on the
last video about the flooding of my
apartment
it's been a bit frustrating but the
floorboards and carpets will be replaced
and just quickly one more thing i've
started up a second channel just for the
music i produce
but i haven't really said anything about
it it's almost at 5 000 subscribers
which is cool
i like it because it's almost like a
small little secret where i'm free to
experiment with stuff
and all of you guys commenting over
there are so nice so thank you it's a
big inspiration
okay so on to the rest of the episode
jeff bezos recently took to the skies in
a private rocket made by his company
blue origin while some people thought
that the engineering aspect was awesome
there were many others that were blind
with rage
it didn't take much for me to see the
consensus online
hate is a strong word but it seems like
a lot of people
really really don't like jeff bezos in
their eyes
they saw a billionaire flaunting his
wealth while the average person was
having a tough time
but is that all why do people hate jeff
bezos so much
in this episode we'll take a look at the
top three reasons at why people are mad
and for the sake of fairness i'll also
supply the counter arguments others hold
i'll be leaving my opinion out of this
one so let's take a look
[Music]
it's important to note that jeff bezos
wasn't born with a silver spoon in his
mouth
he wasn't always a billionaire and it
was a long road to get there
born in 1964 life for baby jeff and his
17 year old mother wasn't easy
jeff's father would drink too much and
cause problems at home
after less than two years of marriage
his parents would divorce
jeff's mother now on her own struggled
to make ends meet while working a
secondary job
she didn't even have enough money to
afford a house phone
determined to make life better for her
and her son she enrolled in college
classes
and the professors permitted her to
bring her baby to class
at college she eventually met and
married mike bezos
a cuban immigrant who would step in as
the father role for jeff
interestingly the now billionaire's
biological father
was once a unicyclist and a circus
performer and when he was tracked down
in 2012
he was running a small bicycle shop
jeff's biological father
reportedly had not seen his son in 50
years
and was utterly confused that his son
was now the ceo of amazon
jeff bezos proved to be a bright but
regular kid
he took up a job at mcdonald's while in
high school after graduating college
he would understand the potential of the
internet and go on to found amazon in
his garage in 1994.
for the full story of that you can check
out the cold fusion episode on amazon
needless to say the venture went very
well
and all of this brings us to today
despite recently stepping down as
amazon's ceo
jeff bezos is still not seen favorably
in the public light
the first reason and the most obvious is
amazon's working conditions and pay
amazon employs one million workers
making it the second largest employer in
the us
and that's after walmart according to
fortune
quote workers at amazon warehouses
across america
state grueling working conditions they
say that they have too few bathroom
breaks which are all timed
excessive productivity goals and an
unsafe working environment
the pandemic only exacerbated problems
as more people turned to delivery
amazon workers had had enough and did
protest working conditions in previous
years
but not much has changed in a press
release the company stated
quote about 40 of work-related injuries
at amazon
are musculoskeletal disorders which
includes sprains or strains
caused by repetitive motions
and for this work the wages are less
than 40k a year or less than about 20
dollars per hour
amazon doesn't see working in their
warehouses as a long-term thing
in fact they stated that employers who
stayed longer became less efficient
while demanding more pay hurting the
business
turnover at amazon is very high with an
annual rate of roughly 150
of warehouse workers amazon is also not
in favor of workers unions here is a
viral 2018 leaked video
meant for managers if you see warning
signs of potential organizing
notify your building hrm and gm site
leader immediately
the most obvious signs would include use
of words associated with unions or
union-led movements like
living wage or steward union graffiti
union t-shirts hats jackets or other
clothing
union flyers some signs are less obvious
than finding the actual union flyer
examples include associates who normally
aren't connected to each other suddenly
hanging out together
groups of associates scatter when
approached by management often it is the
change in behavior that is the warning
sign
more than the actual behavior itself
other problems include
a policy of closely surveilling workers
causing a culture of fear
the cameras are on staff 24 7 and if you
don't meet the standards or rates of
filling
you can be fired there are screens that
show how long you have left to pack each
box
adding additional pressure according to
some workers
you can't talk to others and you
basically scan like a robot the entire
day
and if you're not scanning enough amazon
can file an inquiry
the data that they gather from
everyone's movements is used to optimize
the performance of the company
those on the opposite side argue that
these workers should simply find another
job
or that increasing wages will result in
jobs lost due to automation as
automation will be cheaper for the
company's bottom line
amazon's caver system robots are a prime
example
the second reason that people do not
like jeff bezos is his net worth
bezos is currently the richest man in
the world passing bill gates in 2017.
apart from amazon he owns the news
publication the washington post the
streaming site
twitch audible imdb and the food outlet
whole foods
his net worth is over 200 billion
dollars enough to end hunger in the us
seven times over the pandemic destroyed
countless small businesses in the us
while amazon stayed open doing better
than ever before
and leaving a lot of people resentful
if you were to consider jeff bezos net
worth increase in 2020 an increase of 75
billion dollars
as a wage he would make 8.5 million
dollars per
hour or about 142 thousand dollars per
minute
[Music]
psychologically a lot of people don't
like this why does one person need so
much money
how can one man make significantly more
money in one minute than the average
american does
in one year it seems unfair but that's
not the only reason
people hold disdain the next element is
taxes
in early 2021 irs filings were leaked by
the publication propublica
it revealed that the top 25 richest
people grew their net worth by 401
billion dollars between 2014 and 2018.
despite this they only paid 13.6 billion
dollars in federal taxes
on average about 3.4 of their wealth
gains over this period
these revelations sent shock waves
around social discourse
but things are a bit more complicated
than they seemed on the surface
what most people forget to realize is
that most of the wealth gained by these
billionaires is three increases in the
stock market in which they all have
large holdings
you can blame the monetary policies of
the federal reserve or u.s tax laws for
allowing this to happen
low interest rates and easy money from
the federal reserve allowed stocks to
boom for over a decade
as for the u.s tax law gains in the
stock market is not defined as taxable
income
unless sold in other words the u.s tax
system taxes income
usually in the form of wages and capital
gains but not other forms like stock
market-driven increases in wealth on
paper
and that's just the way it is whether
you think this is fair or not will
depend on your political leaning
propublica also reveals the common
methods of reducing tax for billionaires
propublica explained
the ultra wealthy buy an asset or build
a company or
inherit a fortune as long as they don't
sell they own no
taxes they keep their income as low as
possible
since every dollar they earn can be
taxed
step 2 borrow they borrow against their
holdings
and the bank gives them a really good
deal
i'll loan you 10 million dollars with
only 3 interest
but if you take a 10 million dollar
salary from your company you'll owe
almost 37 percent to the irs
so the ultra wealthy use loan money to
fund their lifestyles
that's how a billionaire can live the
most luxurious life imaginable while
reporting little to no
taxable income step 3 die
when they die these lucky few often use
complicated trusts and philanthropic
foundations to avoid the estate tax
and their heirs can inherit stocks and
other assets
tax free a new generation is ultra
wealthy and the cycle starts all over
again
between 2014 and 2018 warren buffett
paid 10 cents
on every 100 he made elon musk
michael bloomberg and george soros also
did the same thing but to slightly
lesser degrees
in bezos case he was able to pay zero
dollars in tax in some years
by pushing the rules to the extreme and
taking advantage of every loophole
for instance in 2007 he stated that he
made
only 46 million dollars despite his net
worth rising by 3.8 billion
he was able to offset every dollar he
made with losses from side investments
and various deductions like
interest expenses on debt and again in
despite him being worth 18 billion he
reported to the tax agencies a loss
and even received a 4 000 tax credit for
his children
so zooming out a little bit wealth
inequality is now evident to everyone in
the us
and people are starting to get curious
about how it's actually happening
we touched on this extensively in the
cold fusion episode on how money is
created
on top of this seeing bezos pay such
little tax makes people very angry
for them taxes are needed for social
services roads and bridges and social
security so it isn't fair
others will argue that that's just how
the law is and because of that
bezos's money is out of the reach of the
government
a lot of people want to pay for his
products so the company is worth a lot
and it's his money
fair and square to others still who
aren't strictly ideologically driven
they would say that maybe there needs to
be a middle ground solution
let's take a look at our news update
brought to you by morning brew
after jeff bezos landed from his rocket
flight he states that the sales from
private seats on blue origin flights
are already approaching 100 million
quote the demand
is very very high seven thousand six
hundred people
participated in an auction to win a seat
on the most recent flight
and the winning bid was 28 million
dollars according to morgan stanley the
space economy as a whole
could grow to 1 trillion dollars by 2040
if you want to read more stories like
this
and are interested in science technology
and business
morning brew is a great way to do that
it collects all the latest news stories
so you don't have to trundle through
sources manually and it brings them
straight to your inbox
monday to sunday and best of all it's
free it only takes 15 seconds to sign up
so click the link in the description
below to get started
the third and final reason about why
there's so much dislike for jeff bezos
is the government surveillance
connections amazon has another side to
them
the company supplies surveillance
capabilities to the us government
in the form of cloud storage amazon
works with the us immigration and
customs enforcement otherwise known as
ice
but they also work with the department
of homeland security
according to the guardian amazon web
services hosts the dhs databases that
allow the department and its agencies to
track and apprehend immigrants
amazon is also in talks to expand this
to sensitive bio data
including eye color tattoos and other
identifiers
amazon's web services platform also
stores data for the cia
there's also concerns that amazon alexas
can network with each other
even without an internet connection rob
bradman explains
[Music]
alexa echoes are ubiquitous it seems
simple enough it's a voice recognition
device
and it's great for selecting music and
even doing quick internet searches
but truly the average person does not
know that the alexa echo itself
has no voice recognition capability
nada it is not powerful enough to do
voice recognition so it keeps sending
the sounds to amazon to do
voice recognition on the big amazon
servers in the cloud
the amazon cloud servers that's where
the power is
this is why an alexa echo is so cheap it
just
functions as a microphone and speaker
the problem here is that whether you
like it or not
all your voice captures are sent to the
amazon cloud
they didn't tell you that they put
certain features
in the alexa echo in the ring camera
that they would be utilizing
later on like now and that feature my
friends
is a 900 megahertz transmitter and
receiver
that is built into the echos and the
cameras all these products will now
work to create the amazon sidewalk
network amazon echo has the capability
to talk to
or listen to devices in the area up to a
range
of one half mile so if there's another
echo around
all these echoes and ring cameras will
be connected in a mesh network
this went online on june 8th your voice
the camera videos and now the data sense
these devices capture this data
encrypts it and sends it to amazon so
only amazon can see it
now your devices are doing things you
can't even understand
or see there are so many amazon echoes
that every square inch of a big city
could be completely covered by this mesh
network if i went to someone's house
with a ring camera and an echo
i suddenly participate in the spy
network by having my voice captured
and having facial recognition done and
now the amazon sidewalk can then in
theory
capture my phone bluetooth identity and
rfids on my person
and my vehicle and then sidewalk and
determine the location
of each device remember that location of
each echo is known so whatever the echo
finds
is also a location beacon if you want
out of this spy network
you can't just opt out of alexa echo
because you have to opt out
the entire neighborhood as long as
there's someone within half a mile
that has an echo you're docked these
devices will now collect rf data which
will be used to capture information from
devices
and be able to derive locations they
will also be able to control devices
since it is also a transmitter no
internet required or wi-fi
just a private radio network a radio
network
that is not even controlled by the
owners of the devices
but most will basically turn a blind eye
to this and say oh well
i have nothing to light anyway and i
don't need to explain further
and why people don't like this this does
the company image
and hence jeff bezos no favors
so in conclusion jeff bezos is seen as a
man who became filthy rich of multitudes
of workers
in poor conditions his former company
also has close government ties
it's an interesting case because
companies like nike
apple and many other electronic
companies use cheap labor
the nestle company is stealing fresh
water and google
also has ties to the cia but these
companies seem nebulous
yes they all have ceos but mentally to
the outsider
these people aren't seen as closely tied
to their respective companies as jeff
bezos is
when you think of amazon you still think
of jeff bezos
so even though he has left the company
now he might have a hard time
winning people over so what do you guys
think
the best place to discuss this will be
over on the cold fusion discord
i'll leave the links in the description
below alright so that's about it from me
my name is digogo and you've been
watching cold fusion and i'll catch you
again soon for the next
episode cheers
[Music]
you